make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I don't how many of you guys
have been tracking this but Donnie Cates
he went on Twitter a little while ago
and said that absolute carnage was
supposed to be like the definitive
carnage story right like the greatest
carnage story ever told and I believed
him because like like with his one on on
venom like everything he's done on venom
it's been nothing short of spectacular
and the way this first part ends I'm
excited to see what happens but for
those of you guys who are who are kind
of jumping into this for the first time
a couple things I would suggest here the
first is to go back and watch our videos
on venom and and we'll have like I'll
have all the videos down in the
description will probably do a full
story video out of it so you kind of
have your caught up on essentially
everything but then we'll also then also
suggest you guys watch my video on
carnage explained and wait between those
two things you can get caught up
I did call carnage venom a couple times
but people knew what I meant so it's all
good but uh but yeah so this is this is
this is who this is amazing now here's
the cool thing about absolute carnage if
you choose not to do that to really get
caught up on venom to really get caught
up on that the history of carnage you
can still kind of go into this and be
okay I think you'd be better knowing all
that stuff but you know you could still
be okay because in true Donnie Kate's
fashion we get this sort of the
explanation of things that have happened
up to this point right so basically we
get this idea that at one point in time
in the very early days of this universe
right before there was any real life in
it and all you really have with the
Celestials and presumably after they won
their war with the aspirins you had that
you had NOLA symbiote god now of course
as we were told in the the first run of
in on the first volume of venom then all
the symbiote god was this being that was
just sort of out there right you know
kind of existed in this void this little
pocket space inside the universe created
these symbionts to essentially serve as
his agents tried to kind of spread his
influence and chaos throughout the
universe now once he was finally
defeated once this major battle took
place and he was finally locked away
this is what nany keeps kind of ties in
to what Brian Michael Bendis pit right
because if you go back and you read
guardians of the galaxy by Brian Michael
Bendis he introduces the planet of the
symbiote
yeah that the Venom symbiote that that
runs around earth originates from the
this particular planet of the clintus
that's their actual name he said that
the name of the symbionts is called the
clint are that it originated from that
planet where we had previously to just
just believed this is where the soviets
were and according to Brian Michael
Bendis that the Symbian basically
existed it's like space Knights and then
they would bond themselves to a host and
they would go on to perform great deeds
that if something like the Venom
symbiote bonded someone to someone like
Eddie Brock who was filled with anger
and wrath that he would twist the simian
it would warp its beyond it woman be
honest original purpose and it would
essentially become a bad guy
what Donnie Cates is ga'head gone back
him down as he had said that's not
necessarily true
now the symbiotes were created out of
evil and the planet of the symbiotes is
as much a prison as it is a location in
the sims that one snow was defeated he
was locked away inside of his own planet
or I guess inside this planet of the
symbionts and the planet itself is just
a giant ball of symbionts that exists
out there in the universe somewhere and
so once he was defeated they kind of
began changing their tune essentially
became good guys and willingly locked
him away as best they could now the
issue with this this is kind of one of
the cool things that that Donnie Cates
goes into is if you go back and you look
at the history of venom and the various
symbiote so like toxin carnage so on and
so forth shrieking and whatnot you had
this idea where whenever a symbiote left
an existing host and then went to a new
host they would basically maintain
information about their previous host
right it's one of the ways that the
venomous Timmy was able to dodge
spider-man's spider-sense right like
spider-man was the first one to hold a
symbian and then cast it off at the
advice of Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four and so when it left him it felt
betrayed and then returned bonded itself
to Eddie Brock who has already pissed
off a Peter for costing him his job but
it took the knowledge of spider-man with
him right so like the knowledge of
Peters identity the knowledge of
spider-man's spider-sense and how it
functions and how to get around it
that's one of the reasons why the venom
was so capable and so dangerous back in
the day and so the result is that what
donnie cases kind of building on here is
saying that like every time a symbiote
leaves a person that it leaves a little
imprint of itself a tiny little bit of
itself now again this is existing
knowledge this really isn't anything
that Donnie Cates has built off of or I
guess really created out of his out of
his pocket what Donnie Cates did is he
came back and he said these little
codexes these little itty bittys to be
an EM
that are left on a person's DNA if
they're all brought together they can be
used for the purpose of waking up null
on the simia planet and then bringing
him back to life kind of resurrecting
him and that really seems to be the
motivation or at least one of the big
motivations behind the the carnage cult
now what what Donnie kaise is kind of
been tinkering with kind of annoying
with is this idea that Cletus Kasady
wants to resurrect null for the purpose
of killing him and taking this place
taking all of its power and then
controlling all the symbiotes across the
universe and to be honest carnage
becoming God seems pretty insane but
that's really what happens here right
like carnage essentially becomes God in
this in this this this bit and and this
was kind of nuts is because what it does
is it switches over to over to Eddie
Brock now Eddie Brock is really kind of
recounting all this stuff like saying
all these different things and talking
directly to Dylan now again and our
first volume we learned about the
character of Bill and we learned that
Dylan is actually the son of Eddie Brock
but Eddie's basically led Dylan to
believe he's simply his brother and this
is just because of the fact that that
Dylan is a son that Eddie never knew he
had right that was just kind of dropped
off at his father's house by a woman he
was with at one point he ultimately
ended up taking her own life but because
of the fact that his father was so
abusive and he wanted to get him out of
there I'd wanted to get him away from
that from that life and have him live a
normal life the downside of this is that
as they're making their way in New York
City suddenly like all these different
you know digital billboards are met with
like these wanted posters for Eddie
Brock himself and so like the whole
world is aware of who he is the whole
world is aware that like he's a
dangerous man that needs to be needs to
be captured now this is a cool thing
here because when this happens and you
basically have Cletus Kasady
who kind of pops out of nowhere and then
sends Eddie and Dylan flying over into
the really in like the way of this
oncoming subway train now this is one of
the cool things here is because when any
was talking to Dylan about who venom
what I'm sorry who carnage was then
Dylan was kind of like you know the eyes
and ears are like the new person right
like the new reader he was kind of the
new reader in the story in the sense
that people who were just jumping onto
this don't really know the history of
Congress they don't really know the
legacy of carnage they don't really know
the madness that came with Cletus Kasady
the willful abandonment right leg like
just just murdering with abandoned all
these different people that he came
across for no other reason than the fact
that he could but it wasn't like he was
trying to become some super criminal to
amass great wealth or to
to attain absolute power and he did all
these things because he just wanted to
because he just wanted to arbitrarily
take people out that was the kind of
that's the kind of villain that any is
talking about right now and that's again
a villainous one of those we talked
about in our video on carnage explained
it's one of the kind of villains that
you never really see a villain who just
shows up and just arbitrarily takes
people out for no real reason whatsoever
aside from the fact that it's a nihilist
and it just loves to it loves Magnussen
and carnage it loves its own namesake
and so again like what we end up finding
out here is that where Eddie and Dylan
were running away from some man in a
suit that where where Cletus Kasady was
the one who pushed them in front of the
train the man in the suit was actually
the Venom symbiote now those you guys
were kind of playing catch-up here there
came a point during their first fight
with what was essentially this giant
dragon it's this really old Grendel suit
it wasn't really Nova symbiote God
himself so much is like a facsimile of
know kind of like a taste of what would
happen if nul ever came back in like
full and true form not really as
powerful as he could be but certainly
powerful enough to like wreak havoc in
the city of New York
and of course that story culminated with
Eddie Brock grabbing the Venom symbiote
den and because fire is a weakness of
the symbionts pushing no lore at least
his facsimile of null into a furnace but
also seemingly killing the the Venom
symbiote in the process and so the
result was that they were Ted they were
separated for for an amount of time now
following this what you had were
basically two stories being told about
Eddie Brock and then one about the Venom
symbiote the simian itself got its story
in the war of realms right there was
basically dealing with everything with
Malekith and so on and so forth Malekith
dark magic which we'll talk about here
in a second but then you basically had
the story of Eddie trying to make his
way and figure himself out and that was
one of the cool things about this is
because when when the venom venom should
be it shows back up and wants to bond
itself to Eddie the response of Eddie is
no I don't want to like I don't want to
go back to this life again and that's an
important thing because when Eddie first
got the Venom symbiote he saw it as a
tool to be used to defeat Peter Parker
aka spider-man for crossing him
everything he was hell-bent on revenge
and anger and that was basically it
and then you started running into these
stories where Eddie Brock began to sort
of changes tune where he began began to
become like a different kind of care he
became anti-venom for a little while
he began has basically become like a
good guy almost like the the reformation
of Flash Thompson right the high school
bully of Peter Parker who lost his legs
in
military and went on to become agent
venom it's a it's a cool thing in this
scenario because what Eddie Brock has
discovered is the thing that really is
the reader we kind of always knew but
Eddie was never really able to figure
out for himself
that he's highly capable that he's a
very very capable person
now the guilt of Eddie's past life the
idea that he and his friends did hit a
kid when they were younger his father
got him off these are the kind of things
that are sort of driven him that that
kind of made him the villain but the
idea of coming back in trying to reform
trying to be a better person means
casting off that past part of his life
which includes venom being able to
settle down being able to raise his son
and have some small measure of peace is
the guiding force behind Eddie the
problem with this is now carnage is back
and this is no small thing because when
carnage arrives here like all hell
begins to break loose right because
you're talking about about cletus kasady
who for all intents and purposes should
basically be dead toting the power of
one of the original symbionts as it was
created by by null the symbiote God
basically meaning it's more powerful
than Eddie Brock it's more powerful than
venom so this is this is one of the cool
things as that's interesting here
because is it's sort of a tribute of
sorts at least in the first part I mean
not not fully on in terms of the
entirety of the story but in this first
part here it's a tip of the hat to
maximum carnage when the carnage
symbiote vana decreed his Cassidy on the
blood level and he became just way more
powerful than than both Eddie Brock and
spider-man uh he was a force to be
reckoned with
we're essentially dealing with the same
concept except amplified even further
it's the symbiote joined to to Cletus
Kasady on the blood level but it's a
more powerful symbiote than and then the
then both venom and and really like any
other one that we see out there right
now this is an exceedingly dangerous
incredibly powerful carnage just running
around out there right now and like it
really shows because he basically won
punches Eddie Brock he punches him in
the face he breaks his orbital bone his
brain is hemorrhaging I mean in like one
fell swoop Eddie Brock's been taken out
that's the kind of carnage that we're
dealing with back in the day it was
really more like Carnage's durability
about his ability to create all kinds of
different sharp appendages and someone
and so forth and his insanity that made
him almost unpredictable that's really
what made him so such a such a huge
force back in the day and this one it's
just like the sheer force of the
symbiote he wields the power
he possesses is enough to like take out
Eddie Brock in one hit and so what Eddie
does is respond in kind
doing the only thing he can do grabbing
it like grabbing the electrical lines of
the of where the subway train was and
then grabbing Venna or grabbing a
carnage and then just electrocuting the
piss out of them and basically it
destroys the carnage symbiote for you
know in the interim but all it really
does is really just kind of like
temporarily send it into chaos and
that's basically it it's a stopgap
measure and Eddie knows this right Eddie
knows this is a stopgap measure he knows
there's no real way as far as he's aware
to defeat carnage in the traditional
sense and again that makes sense because
in the maximum carnage storyline it
really took the combined efforts of
spider-man and venom to pull it off now
even the first time a met before maximum
carnage it took the combined efforts of
Veneman and Peter Parker you know
spider-man to defeat this guy and so
again we're dealing with a super amped
up very powerful version of carnage and
so as a result of this the Venom
symbiote shuts down the mind of Eddie
Brock puts him in a coma to a catatonic
state while he basically heals his body
and then takes him to the only place the
one place where they can get any real
measure of help and it's a cool thing
because we all knew this was coming we
all knew it was only a matter of time
before this happened what ends up
happening here is that once they arrived
to Liszt's location the symbiote wakes
up Eddie Brock and they knock on the
door of an apartment and when this
happens somebody answers the door and
that's what we end up finding out the
person the Venom symbiote took Eddie
Brock to the only real person he'd be
able to get any help from in this
situation or the very least the only one
who would listen to him is Peter Parker
spider-man without being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
[Music]